COLLEEN BRIANT: Hi, I'm Colleen.
DANA HOFFMAN: Hey, I'm Dana.
Colleen and I are software
engineers at Google.
We work on Google
Cloud Platform.
And today, we're
going to show you
how to use the Cloud Foundry
service broker for Google Cloud
Platform that we
built in collaboration
with the engineers at Pivotal.
So Colleen, you took the lead
building the service broker.
Can you give us an overview
of what a service broker is?
COLLEEN BRIANT: Sure.
A service broker is a special
kind of Cloud Foundry app
that developers can use to
quickly and easily spin up
instances of different services,
and then get credentials
for their applications to use.
It's integrated into
the Cloud Foundry CLI,
so developers can stay focused.
And Cloud Foundry
operators can manage
the kinds of services and
plans that their developers
have access to.
DANA HOFFMAN: Cool.
So what's the quickest,
easiest way to actually get
a service broker installed?
COLLEEN BRIANT: So
the service broker
is available as a tile
on network.Pivotal.io.
So if you're using Pivotal
Ops Manager, the easiest way
to get up and running is
just to go that route.
And normally this takes
about half an hour.
But for the purposes
of this video,
I'm going to cut out
some of the waiting time.
And all this is documented
on docs.Pivotal.io.
But if you want to
follow along with me,
here are the steps you
would need to run through.
To get started with
the service broker,
you need to create
a new GCP project
if you don't already have one.
Then you'll need to create a new
service account for the broker
to use for all of its calls,
and give it owner level
access to your project.
You'll need to enable the IAM
and cloud resource manager
APIs, as well as the APIs
for any other services you
want to enable.
Then you'll need to
set up a database
to back the service broker.
You can use any MySQL
database you want.
But if you'd like
to use Cloud SQL,
you can set up your
database in the console
using default settings.
Except that you'll want
to enable network access
for Many IP, restrict
access to SSL connections,
and create a set of SSL
certs for the service broker
to connect with.
After setting up your project
and database and enabling APIs,
you'll download the
tile from [INAUDIBLE].
Add it to your Ops
Manager installation.
When you first add
it, you'll need
to go through some
configuration steps.
First, you'll need to
add the credentials
for the service account you gave
owner access to your project.
And then you'll
need to configure
access and credentials
for the database that
backs the service broker.
Lastly, if you as
an operator want
to expose Cloud SQL
to your developers,
you'll need to
configure some custom
plans based on machine type,
disk size, and pricing plan.
Once you're all done
with configuration,
the tile will turn
green, and you'll
be able to apply your changes.
When Ops Manager
finishes updating--
all of these services will be
available in the marketplace.
Documentation for this
installation process,
as well as for using
the service broker,
is available on docs.Pivotal.io.
But if you're not
using Ops Manager,
and you just wanted
to deploy the service
broker as an app to your
Cloud Foundry installation,
it's publicly
available on GitHub.
And instructions for installing
an app as a service broker
are available on
docs.CloudFoundry.org.
COLLEEN BRIANT: And Dana, we
walked through this together
recently, and you were able
to build a super cool app that
uses the service broker.
Can you show us what you built?
COLLEEN BRIANT: Sure.
And thank you, I think
it's pretty cool too.
I built a [INAUDIBLE]
application
which scrapes Reddit
for cute animal photos,
classifies them using the
Google Cloud Vision API,
stores them in
Google Cloud Storage,
and displays the results.
At this point, I've uploaded my
application to Cloud Foundry.
But it won't run since it
has no valid credentials.
To generate credentials and
create my Cloud Storage Bucket,
I used the service broker.
The first step is to
create a storage service.
I've named the storage bucket
[INAUDIBLE] Vision Bucket.
And I'll refer to it with that
name from within the code.
You can also let the service
broker generate a bucket name,
and have your code pull that
name from the environment.
Next, I'll bind it
to my application,
and give the service account
admin permissions for my cloud
storage bucket.
Now we have everything we
need to parse the credentials
from within our application.
Restaging the app
takes a few minutes.
So in the meantime, let's
take a look at the code.
The credentials are stored in
the vCAB Services Environment
Variable.
So our application parses
that variable as JSON
and stores it in a
Google credential
object, which can then be used
to access the APIs we need.
Now that it's running,
let's take a look.
There's nothing in our
storage bucket yet.
So the app is pretty empty.
Let's run the scrape.
And there we have it, cute
animal pictures with labels
generated from the
Google Cloud Vision API,
all served out of
Google Cloud Storage.
COLLEEN BRIANT: Ah.
That's really cool.
How long did it take
you to build that?
DANA HOFFMAN: So when I first
started working on the app,
I was brand-new to
the service broker.
But it still took
me just a few hours
to get it working within my
app, and to feel like I actually
understood what I was doing
and how the whole thing worked.
Once I had it
working here, I was
able to use it in
another app later.
And whole integration
took under an hour.
COLLEEN BRIANT: Awesome.
So do you have any
tips or best practices
for anybody else looking
to build an application
with a service broker?
DANA HOFFMAN: Sure.
One best practice tip
that I'd like to mention
is using curated IM
roles for your bindings.
These are rules that restrict
access to a single GCP service.
As you saw earlier, when I bound
to my service instance created
through the service broker,
I passed a custom parameter,
which is the IM role that
controls what resources
the application has access to.
For the sake of
security, we advise
using curated roles so
your application has
as few privileges as possible.
You can see examples of
this in the service broker
documentation on
docs.Pivotal.io.
And you can find out
more about curated roles
in the IM documentation
on cloud.Google.com.
This is awesome.
Service broker's
really great, right?
COLLEEN BRIANT: Yeah.
Service broker, best broker.
DANA HOFFMAN: Best broker.
COLLEEN BRIANT:
Thanks for watching.
Check out our playlist and
more videos on Cloud Foundry,
and make sure to subscribe
to the Google Cloud channel.